900 panneaux comme celui ci vont faire
leur apparition dans les rues
résidentielles de l'arrondissement
rosemont petite patrie
l'idée ici c'est pas moins de voitures
c'est plus lentement de voiture
toutefois la vitesse ne changera pas sur
les grandes artères comme saint denis où
heureusement faut pas non plus faire en
sorte que ce à cause de problèmes et de
congestion supplémentaires qu'ils
viennent de mire aussi à la qualité de
vie parce que là il ya toute la question
des nations des gaz à effet de serre
compagnie donc il ya toujours le
l'équilibré qu'il faut trouver le maire
de l'arrondissement estime qu'en réalité
les voitures rouleront un peu plus vite
mais que la nouvelle limite aura tout de
même des vertiges chaque kilomètre de
réduction réduit les risques de décès
lors d'une collision donc de réduire de
10 km à 7,1 gains importants en termes
de risque et de santé publique
au moins quatre arrondissements ou
amorcer ce virage à 30 km heure dans les
rues résidentielles ses résidantes du
sud ouest n'avaient pas vraiment
remarqué la nouvelle signalisation
installés au printemps ce tranquille
avoue aussi ce support
ça n'a jamais été un gros trafic ou un
excellent d'itv témoin j'en ai jamais
remarqué way puis les voitures des fous
est sûr que la paix vite ce qui va être
important ce projet faisait baisser
cette s'assurer que ce soit respectée le
maire de montréal rappelle qu'après la
réfection de la rue sainte-catherine
la vitesse y sera aussi réduite en fait
de plus en plus d'aménagements urbains
de règlement et de limites contraignent
les usagers de la route qui finissent
par s'en accommoder comment vous trouvez
ça comme motocycles c'est bien parce qu
il ya beaucoup d étudiants est très
petit garçon et fille du travers le roux
c'est plus sage
les services de police de la ville de
montréal ne put encore mesurer l'impact
sur le nombre d'accidents on n'a pas non
plus cherché à savoir s'il y a eu plus
de constats d'infraction émis dans les
rues où les automobilistes doivent
désormais mettre la [ __ ] douce ici and
with despatie radio canada montréal